Only the light
[Music] It's fine if the
goblins are still sleeping. It's
not a goblin.
Goblin Slayer, you're not
sleeping. You're not sleeping.
So what do you think? There were more goblins this time.
How many were there?
Oh, I'd like to ask one by one. The first one was
34, and Taras. I
confirmed that Talas dived and saved the prisoners and sunk the element. There were
34 corpses. There were 10 left. Oh,
how about the second one? Goblins.  There were
3 goblins at 20 degrees, and when they came out in smoke, they
collapsed the ceiling and crushed them.The
remaining ones were strong enough to kill them one by one.The weapons they
used were those of dead goblins.Stop it,
goblins are a big deal.  Even if you don't
say so, just to be
safe, try to get robbed by some evil beast.You look like the
Goblin Slayer.If you're being
called upon, please teach me how to kill goblins.No, I
won't take action until I learn.  If that's the case, even if I learn, nothing will
change. I'm sorry it's so
late. Thank you for your help.